Hey youtubers it’s Charlie Hail Hydra.
So This week’s Agents of SHIELD was a direct
continuation of the end of Winter Soldier.
In terms of pacing it really is the start
of the final plot arc of season 1.
What I’m going to do first is talk about
how the movie and the tv show connected, then
top 5 moments, then my review.
During that part I’ll also address what
all the shit hitting the fan means for season
2 if the show gets renewed.
Also heads up, my bonus Marvel video this
week will be a Captain America 3 video.
I think I’ve figured out which comics they’re
going to be using for it.
Be sure to subscribe to get it if you’re
finding me for the first time.
So let’s talk about Winter Soldier crossing
into Agents of SHIELD.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the movie or this episode.
The timeline is like this, they HYDRA helicarrier
strike started right before this episode started.
The end of Winter Soldier, when Captain America
destroys them, happens just as they are capturing
Agent Garrett and his men.
They’re at the Triskelion.
Remember they parked the Bus in the same hanger
we saw in the movie.
When Victoria Hand said Captain America’s
whereabouts are unknown, that’s around the
time he was at Nick Fury’s grave with Anthony
Mackie.
Nick Fury still wants everyone to think he’s
dead.
So Coulson and Hand still don’t know he
survived.
He’s off trying to track down more rogue
HYDRA agents.
Captain America and Anthony Mackie are doing
the same thing separately while they hunt
for the Winter Soldier.
So this episode ended pretty much at the same
time the Winter Soldier movie ended.
Obviously the show has 5 more episodes.
But we can talk about where it’s headed
after my top 5 moments.
And they are:
Number 5 - Skye Decodes The HYDRA activation
message
The message was sent to all the HYDRA double
agents telling them to sieze control of SHIELD.
That went out while they were launching the
Helicarriers in the movie.
When Crossbones and Robert Redford revealed
who they really were.
I love the reaction of Coulson and the crew.
Since I saw the movie last week, the surprise
wasn’t as wasted, but I loved those lines.
Out of the shadows and into the light.
Time to face the Hydra Music.
Which makes me wonder, what does the Hydra
theme music sound like?
Maybe like the Star Wars Imperial March.
Number 4 - May Comes Clean About TAHITI
Before this, there were two people I thought
she could be reporting to based on her alliegance.
Robert Redford and Nick Fury.
I’m glad she turned out to not be a double
agent for HYDRA.
How cool was it that she basically inceptioned
their whole team into Coulson’s head via
Fury.
Like she gave Fury all their names and Fury
suggested them to Coulson.
I’m curious to see what her relationship
with him will be like once they dust settles.
I’m expecting some game changing May save
in the finale that makes him start trusting
her again.
But for the next couple of episodes she’ll
just be an ally.
Not a friend.
Number 3 - Victoria Hand’s HYDRA Fakeout
One of the many awesome fakeouts in the episode.
When we saw that end teaser last week that
revealed she was remote piloting the plane
I was pretty sure she wasn’t the clairvoyant.
So when she gave them the HYDRA speech I was
actually surprised.
In the comics Victoria Hand works for HAMMER,
but she isn’t outright evil like HYDRA.
When she took it all back and said they passed
the test I was relieved.
Had she been an actual HYDRA agent, they probably
would have had to eventually kill her off
the show unless she was going to go on to
become some new big bad.
And nothing I saw gave me the impression that
she was going to be a season 2 big bad.
Number 2 - Garrett is the Clairvoyant
Surprisingly not the biggest reveal in the
episode.
Bill Paxton does such an amazing job of playing
sleazebag characters, how could we not have
known he would turn out to be a sleazebag
double agent for HYDRA.
To be fair, he wasn’t always HYDRA, he said
he saw the wind blowing in their direction
and switched sides.
So I think when he and Coulson were training
together under Nick Fury he was still on the
good side.
In the comics Garrett eventually became an
Avenger, but he was a pretty awful person
before all that happened.
I’ll talk more about where I think his character
is headed in a sec.
and my Number 1 WTF moment - Ward Is Hydra.
Or Is He?
Huge reveal, Ward shoots Victoria Hand and
the guards so we’re supposed to think he’s
either HYDRA or just decided to turn right
there on the spot.
But wait, let’s think about this for a sec.
Personally I think he’s just playing Garrett
in order to uncover who the other top level
HYDRA agents are.
Like Ward is a double double agent.
So he’s still a good guy.
What about the gun shots though?
Did he really kill Victoria Hand?
We didn’t see blood and remember Couslon
told them to use the night night guns when
they first landed at SHIELD headquarters.
We never saw him switch guns, so he probably
was still using the stun gun and it only appeared
he was using real bullets.
I don’t remember them ever telling Agent
Garrett about the Night Night Gun technology.
That was something Fitz developed on his own.
It’s not normal SHIELD technology.
Thus I think either next week or in a couple
more episodes.
We’ll find out Ward is secretly on a mission
and he’s not a HYDRA agent.
So real quick here are just some bonus favorite
moments that I thought were really amazing.
Garrett give Agents Stilwell a shout out for
hiring so many HYDRA agents.
Garrett tries to recruit Fitz to be HYDRA’s
new Arnim Zola, May calls out Ward for having
a hard on for Skye and then Skye and Ward’s
let’s have a drink moment.
They’re officially the second biggest ‘ship
on the show next to Coulson and the Cellist.
We’re actually going to meet the cellist
pretty soon.
She’s being played by Amy Acker.
Now it’s your turn though, let me know what
your favorite moment was?
Was it all the fakeouts?
Learning Garrett was the true Clairvoyant
or the Ward reveal at the end?
Overall I rate the episode as a solid B plus.
It did a good job of incorporating this huge
convoluted movie plot from Winter Soldier,
a two and a half hour movie.
Not an easy job.
And it revealed all these new layers in the
existing characters.
I love what they’re doing with the relationships
on the team.
Not just the sexual relationships, the friendships
like Coulson and May.
I fully expect all the broken trust issues
to be fixed by the end.
But the HYDRA cat and mouse chase is going
to be so much fun to watch between now and
then.
They slipped in
a couple nice callbacks to Gravitonium, I
keep expecting Graviton to bust out of the
fridge with all this chaos happening.
And I have to say I was honestly surprised
that the Clairvoyant wasn’t Arnim Zola,
it was Garrett a real person all along.
I was a little dissapointed.
I really liked the idea of AI being evil given
the plot of Avengers 2.
The only other thing I really didn’t like
about the episode was that scene where they’re
carting Garrett off and it’s in slow motion
with this weird music track.
It just felt really odd.
It would have been better if Triplett had
just rushed up and tackled him like the Hulk.
Real Quick let’s talk about what SHIELD
crashing down says about Season 2 of the show.
It hasn’t been renewed yet even though every
single other show on ABC has gotten a renewal
or cancellation notice.
They haven’t said anything about SHIELD.
I think it’s because they’re trying to
hide or at least hold off on revealing what’s
going to happen during the season finale.
I’ll be talking more about this in my Bonus
Captain America 3 video tomorrow, because
it’s all about the Secret Avengers comic.
SHIELD gets destroyed and Captain America
puts together a separate team of his own to
go on covert missions.
I think the show Agents of SHIELD will be
doing something like this in season 2 if it’s
not cancelled.
Like I said, I’ll explain more in the bonus
video tomorrow.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
Let me know what your final thoughts on the
episode were.
Did you think the episode did a good job of
holding up the suspense from the movie?
I saw the movie almost a week ago, I think
the episode would have seemed better if I’d
seen the movie right before seeing it.
But it was still a lot of fun.
Next week Patton Oswalt is guest starring,
so be sure to watch.
In the meantime you can click here for that
bonus Captain America 3 Secret Avengers video.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
And you can click here for my other picks
for a Captain America 3 story.
Thanks for watching, Hail Hydra.